نعت في اوساط خليجيه وعربيه الفنان
الكويتي عبد الكريم عبد القادر الذي وافته
المنيه عن واحد وثمانين عاما قدم فيها
الراحل واعمالا خالده ارتبطت بوجدان محبين
التقرير التالي يوجد قليلا من كثير سيد
الوداع
وتغرب الصوت الجريح كما اعتاد محبه تسميته
رحل الرجل الثمانيني تاركا ارثا فنيا
كبيرا جاوز السته عقود من مئات الاغنيات
التي رسمت قصص عشق لا تنتهي في فضاء
الموسيقى الكويتيه والخليجيه
غربه لن تستطيع تغيب رمز من رموز الفن
الخليجي عبد الكريم عبد القادر وطنا
[موسيقى]
لها صوت الكويت الاكثر وعراقه وصرخه بلاده
حين داهمها الغزو لم يفارق ترابها واظل
صوته الرقيق هادرا فوق اصوات المدافع حتى
عادت ارضه الى ناسها
[موسيقى]
وبيح في الهوا
نجاحاته ظلت متالقه بصوته واصوات فناني
الكويت والخليج طوال عقود وحضوره الدائم
في وجدان عشاق الموسيقى الاصيله لم يغب
يوما رغم غيابه عن الحفلات الموسيقيه
لعقود
اخر ليله تجمعنا
وداعيه اعز الناس ودعنا لطالما كان الوداع
في اغنيات عبد الكريم عبد القادر عنوانا
اللامعا رغم الشجن وقاسيا غير مره مثل ما
كان وداعه المفاجئ والهادر طوال تجربه
حفظت اصاله الكلمه وعراقه اللحن ناسجا
بصوته المخملي اغنيات خالده في تاريخ
الموسيقى العربيه
مكانه
الخالي معهد
الملك محدم
سته عقود من الفن الفارق في مسيره الاغنيه
الكويتيه والخليجيه يتركها الراحل لعشاقه
لتبقى مسيرته الخالده عنوانا للولا الذي
يطرا على بال محبيه ولا يجدون ملاذا الا
في حنجره الصوت الجريح
[موسيقى]
على بالا يطري عليه الولاء والظليل على
بال يا مرحبا
[موسيقى]
على بالي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات